welcome to the stage author of Molly's
game Molly bloom
[Applause]
hello everyone
so I am here with Simon sinek
yes and the way I met Simon is kind of
strange
I became friends with some of the police
Chiefs in my town
because I'm a friend of law enforcement
now
rule following citizen
and um
one of the police Chiefs she's a woman
she's extraordinary she said you have to
meet Simon sinek
and I said I I'm a huge fan how do you
know him and she said I'm part of this
group that he put together to improve
upon law enforcement and that is just
Simon the way he lives his life there's
no problem too complex too big he has a
vision of the world a better world a
more just World a more Humane world and
he doesn't just talk about it he gets
into action
uh the work he's done with
leaders and organizations has catalyzed
an evolution of culture out from a
fear-based self-preservationist mind and
into a higher more conscious state so it
is such an honor to be here to talk
about his life and his work and the Art
of impact so Simon hello thanks Molly
yeah
Molly bloom
[Applause]
it wasn't a light lift this vision of
yours this vision of a better world
on our pre-call we talked about at the
beginning you were booed you were
heckled your credibility was called into
question people said things like you
don't understand business
and yet you persisted so my question is
where does your why come from and where
does this deep Relentless conviction
behind it
I think that it's it's I think of a like
an artist's sensibility if you talk to
an artist
and say why do you paint why do you
dance
they don't understand the question
the answer they give is I can't not
right it's there's compulsion and not
all ideas uh have compulsion you know
they don't feed our souls and you know I
think for for probably shared by a lot
of people in this room you know the
question is is what ideas should we be
stubborn with and what ideas should we
know when to quit and I think it's often
often a debate like you have to know
when to quit and you should never quit
and I think the answer is if you can't
stop thinking about it if the idea has
so much Soul at the old it it just
compels you those are the ones that we
never quit we're the other ones sure you
you can sort of figure out a time to
walk away and that is what this became
for me
um uh it was something I couldn't not do
um and when you have that kind of
belief in something desperate belief and
people have it in their families they
have it in their faith they have
Desperate belief in something
um the the criticism
um becomes part of the fun
frankly
um you I mean the story you're you're
told you're talking about is true it
happened in the early days when I was
talking about start with Y I was on a
stage talking to a a fairly large group
of entrepreneurs and business owners and
um
the very first it wasn't a question the
very first statement made when we went
to q a a guy just with the microphone
said
um uh I think you're naive
um I don't think you're you've never run
a multi-billion dollar company
I think your ideas are uh useless in the
real world and I don't think it'll ever
work
um and my answer was so don't do it
next question like and and it's not
because I'm I'm was being difficult it's
because I never saw my job
to convince people because I don't think
I'm right
and I don't think that I have answers I
think I have a point of view that's all
and so I'm simply sharing my point of
view and if you don't share my point of
view I'm totally fine with that you know
if you want to run your business your
way you run it your way I just think
business could run this way
um and so I never took it personally
quite frankly when when I got comments
like that or when they questioned my my
credentials or anything like that
you never took it personally or you were
able to reframe it
no I didn't I didn't genuinely didn't
take it personally okay like like I mean
it happened at another one where the
very first question was what are your
credentials after I've just given this
whole speech you know and I said none
and just so he knew I wasn't joking I
elaborated and said I have no Advanced
degrees I made no formal study of this
this is just my point of view
um and I think
I think one of the things that we have
to remember and I think young people
don't realize this is when someone gives
you a shot
when they decide to put you on a stage
and give you a microphone or if they
give you a job or if they um open a door
for you or make an introduction for you
you don't have to prove yourself because
you've already been vetted
somebody else has already said I mean
you see this in new employees all the
time you know the company Chanel like
Chanel
they have this rule that I absolutely
love that new new senior executives are
not allowed to speak in meetings for the
first 90 days of their employment
they want you to shut up and listen and
the reason they do that is because new
employees so often feel they have to
talk in every meeting to prove that you
made the right choice to hire them like
we know you're smart we hired you
shut up and learn and I and I and I
think that's correct and and I and and
yeah
I have nothing else
[Applause]
at what point
was it in your childhood was it in I
mean at what point did you decide this
was your why and this was your mission
and you were going to not quit
so no one decides what their why is your
why is inside you and if you're
fortunate enough to go on the Journey of
discovery
um what's not fortunate enough if you
choose to go on the Journey of Discovery
um and you're able to put that Y into
words so the thing that drives your gut
like there's no part of your stomach
that makes decisions right you know your
gut feeling comes from somewhere uh and
it is this deep-seated purpose cause or
belief that we all have because we're
all products of our upbringing and you
are who you are and
um and so for me it wasn't a question of
um
uh deciding on it but it was discovering
it and not uncommon
you can go through a process of
discovery because you just decide you
want to
um or you can very often struggle uh
reveals your why to you
um I think that's probably very much
your case as well you know you had to
hit the bottom before you realized who
you were
um uh and my story is not dissimilar
either way I didn't go to I'm not a
convicted felon
um
[Music]
um uh
but you're my favorite convicted fellain
the
the the
but I I had to like I had to face uh
what I thought was bankruptcy had to
face collapse I had to face
um humiliation
um uh to to discover what my cause was
and and I think you probably share this
as well which is I couldn't have done
that alone and it it took a friend
coming to me in this very dark place
that I spent all of my energy pretending
that I was happy more successful and
More in control than I really felt
um uh and lying hiding and faking is
exhausting
um and it it took a friend to say
something's not right even my I was so
good at it even my family didn't
recognize it and but this friend did and
I came clean and all of the energy went
into that was going into line hiding and
faking went into
Um rediscovering passion
um and it wasn't the discovering of my
why that set me on the path it was the
discovering of my why and then wanting
desperately to share with my friends
because I love my friends and I want
them to have what I found
and they started making Crazy Life
Changes and making these huge decisions
with total confidence
and they would invite me to their homes
to share with their friends and I would
literally stand in someone's living room
talking about this thing called the Y
and that's what ignite ignited the spark
that I realized that I I had something
to give
um and you discover you discover service
I mean this is what a life of service
means which is
um you know the reason you know people
keep talking about or we're told you
have a gift you know well the very
definition of a gift is it's supposed to
be given and I think that if you have a
gift and you're not sharing it I think
you're just selfish
what if we don't know Roi how do we
unearth it there's many ways to do it
um you know I I've
written a book about about it find your
why and we have like stuff online to
help people find it but there's multiple
ways to do it
um uh
uh I can tell you a fun way some of you
may know about it it's called the
friends exercise
which is really fun which is go to a
friend who you love and who loves you
um the kind of friend that if you called
them at three o'clock in the morning you
know they would take your call and if
they called you you would absolutely be
there for them do not do this with a
sibling do not just do with a parent and
do not do this with a spouse it doesn't
work
um because they think they know you
um no I go to a friend a friend and and
who you love and ask them this very
simple question
why are we friends
and they're gonna look at you like
you're crazy
because you're asking them to put into
words a feeling and the part of the
brain that controls our emotions doesn't
control language so we struggle and
ironically you actually stop asking the
question why because the question why
elicits emotional responses and you
convert to a rational question come on
you'll say What specifically is it about
me that I know that you would be there
for me no matter what
and they will struggle and they will hem
and the ha and they go
I don't know and they'll start
describing you
are trustworthy you're funny
um you're always there for me and you
have to play Devil's Advocate and you go
great that's the definition of a friend
What specifically is about me then I I
know you'd be there for me no matter
what and they're gonna go through a few
rounds of this you cannot help them you
cannot let anybody else help them you
have to let them go through the stress
and eventually after a bunch of rounds
they will give up
and they will stop describing you and
they will start talking about themselves
and my friends said to me Simon I don't
know all I know is I don't even have to
talk to you I can just sit in a room
with you and I feel inspired and I got
goosebumps in fact I'm getting them
right now
and uh that's because they put into
words something that is deep inside of
me and you will you know you've you're
you're there when you have the emotional
response to what they're describing
about themselves you will well up you
will have Goosebumps something will
happen and if you do this with multiple
friends you will get similar if not the
exact same answer because the thing you
give to the world your why is the reason
they love you it's the thing they want
in their life that fills that missing
Gap that they don't have which is why
we're not friends with everyone
so it's a wonderful wonderful way to to
find your why I love that
kind of the next
is that inflection point before that was
that the Tipping Point where people
started to embrace
this concept
how long were you out there speaking how
long before
diffusion Theory essentially took place
uh so this is the thing that is just for
me fascinating about learning the
discipline of starting with y and
following the religion of law of
diffusion of Innovations which is
ignoring the majority and finding the
early adopters which which is religion
to me I I base my whole career and
that's how ideas spread on that
beautiful idea
um it happened immediately
the minute I started talking about what
I believed and start and stopped talking
about what I did
things happened immediately so for
example if I would go to a dinner party
where you sit on a plane and somebody
says what do you do and you actually
answer that question if you're lucky to
find 10 of the people who are actually
interested in that you can have a
conversation
um but if you talk about what you
believe
you talk about
um how you view the world
um people who believe what you believe
were instantly drawn to you and people
who don't believe what you believe don't
care and will walk away and the people
who are instantly drawn to you will say
things like this is someone I need to
introduce you to and so my career went
from fine and it went like this so I'll
just give you one example I first
publicly articulated the concept of the
Golden Circle and starting with why in
January of 2006
okay
bye
I think it was about May
or June of 2006 I was standing in the
Pentagon presenting to the chief of
staff and Secretary of the of the Air
Force so one of the members of The Joint
Chiefs I'm the same idiot
okay nothing has changed the difference
was the way I got there was I talked
about what I believed and said that
somebody I need you to meet that's how I
got my book deal somebody said to me I
went out to dinner with somebody I talk
about what I believe they said I need to
introduce you to this editor I tell I
have a conversation I tell them what I
believe he says I need you to meet my
publisher I have a 29-minute
conversation with the publisher and
three days later they offered me a book
deal
and and it's only because I worked very
hard to talk about what I believed you
have to eventually talk about what you
do because people want proof
it's that it's not that I think the
what's unimportant it's that the order's
wrong people talk about what they do
they talk about how they do it they
rarely talk about what they believe I
talk about what I believe how I do it
and then I'll tell you about what I do
so and the order matches the biology of
human decision making which is why it
works can you talk a little bit about
that biology because I think it's
fascinating how you back these theories
up with neuroscience
yeah I mean and it's not very it's not
very controversial it's it's not
Neuroscience 101 right so
um it's really basic stuff which is good
um because I'm not a neuroscientist the
um but I did check everything out with a
nurse
uh uh
uh you know I think there's a lot of
ideas in the market that
the the sellers of those ideas
um whether their commercial ideas or
just philosophical ideas the sellers of
those ideas that the spreaders of those
ideas are looking for the buyers to just
believe or take it on faith like the
universe will provide that's one of my
favorite ones you just ask the universe
you know and I'm totally fine with that
but my question is
why does the universe do that
like I want to know the reason why that
happens like I'm not satisfied with if
you start with talking about what you
believe then things will follow I know
it's to be true but why and if you ask
that question enough times necessarily
you end up at the origins of the human
species and anthropology and biology and
why this Legacy machine was built the
way it it was to respond to the world
around us so that we will survive
and so necessarily when you start asking
the questions about those things that
we're asked to take on faith you you end
up at biology and anthropology and it
sort of all starts to make sense it also
helps you understand why things don't
work right um or when our systems get
short-circuited you know we're a very
old machine living in a very modern
world we're not Built For This
so kind of the next step in this
Evolution was
Leaders Eat Last
and you expanded your ideas outside of
self and this motivation and this
passion into a more Universal approach
that was in direct contradiction to the
way that the culture of business and
Leadership was at the time getting away
from the jackwellship at all and into
more Humane leadership uh
and the part there's many parts of this
work that's so fascinating to me but one
that I think is so profound is starting
to understand the conditions under which
humans thrive
um and you do you do a lot of uh talking
about fear and safety and keep and you
know business up until this point it was
very much about hitting people against
each other uh the bottom line
shareholder Supremacy just these
conditions that are completely
antithetical to how humans survive and
thrive and our product productive
what was it were you already working
with the military at this point
so I'd have a so the Air Force were
early adopters of my work I mean right
from the beginning and so I'd had a I'd
continue to have a long relationship
what's interesting about the story of
humanity and the concept of leadership
last first of all the title leadership
last comes from a conversation I had
with a marine right I said what makes
Marines better than all the other all
the others and he said officers eat last
and it's a concept shared across the
military it just happened to be with a
marine that's where that title comes
from and the opening story in leader Z
last is a war story
um you know I like to joke that they're
that uh in the military they give medals
to people who are willing to sacrifice
themselves so that others May gain and
in business we give bonuses to people
who are willing to sacrifice others so
that we may gain right
and
uh um but the true origin story for
leaders eat less which is not in the
book
was
um when uh came from an ex and I don't
talk about it that often I have talked
about it but I don't talk about that
often which is I had the opportunity to
go to Afghanistan
uh with the Air Force
um I had been doing a lot of work with
the mobility forces era the air Mobility
forces
um are the branch of the Air Force that
um are responsible for all of the the
big planes that don't
drop bombs or shoot bullets so no
fighter jets no bombers but the tankers
the cargo planes Air Force One all of
that stuff belongs to air Mobility
command and the general who's in charge
you know he said you know you've got to
know us really well but it would mean a
lot to me if you would be willing to go
to Iraq or Afghanistan to see our men
and women perform their Duty I would
like you to see what they do would you
be willing to go
and I said yes
um and they chose Afghanistan and I
didn't tell my family and very few
friends
um for the simple reasons I didn't want
them to worry
I told my parents that I was going away
with the Air Force for a few days true I
told him I was going to Germany
true
I told him I'd be on a lot of planes I'd
probably be out of touch for a while
true I just didn't tell them I was going
from Germany to Afghanistan
and minor detail minor detail and it
became very real when I was at Dover Air
Force Base uh which is where we left
from and the first thing we got was a
tour of the mortuary where all the
Fallen Soldiers came through Dover
and then we went and I got fitted for my
uh Kevlar vest and helmet and they asked
me do you want the extra ceramic plate
like yes
um we flew
we flew uh to Germany on a C5 amazing
experience big big huge cargo plane with
like whole helicopters in the back
um and then we flew tobagrum uh on a
kc-135 tanker and the Air Force was
stretched so thin that they were using
tankers to bring inbounded stuff these
planes aren't designed to land in war
zones they have no defensive
capabilities they have no flares they
have nothing
and everything was fine
um and we landed in Bagram and the the
side door of the plane was open but we
were still on the plane we hadn't got
enough and we'd been on the ground maybe
10 minutes this is 10 o'clock at night
it's middle of the night they do that
for safety because we have no defensive
measures
um uh we're on the ground for maybe 10
minutes and the base came on a rocket
attack
and three rockets hit 100 yards off our
nose and you could hear them and the air
raid sirens blared and this through the
speaker they told everybody to go to
their bunkers to cover
and we are on a plane
and there's nothing we could do and and
nobody put on their helmets or their
vests because
our plate is filled with gas that's not
going to do anything
and everybody was weirdly relaxed and
for those who View and I think there's a
couple of you in the audience who've
been in a war zone you you have all the
feelings you're supposed to have but you
don't have them at the right times
so I was relaxed yeah
um the Aryan Sirens turned off the all
clear was given and we could go to our
quarters we went to our quarters me and
my two escorts two officers who went
with me and
um and my only responsibility was to do
an airdrop Mission and they're not
regularly scheduled so we went to our
quarters we got like two maybe three
hours of sleep if we're really lucky got
up super early in the morning then we uh
did an airdrop in a C-17 where we flew
an hour and a half out to the middle of
Afghanistan to afford operating base
dropped down to 2000 feet the big door
open at the back and supplies parachuted
out the back and we were sitting right
there watching it happen it was an
incredible experience
come back to Bagram after the mission
was completed and now the goal is to
leave the country
and nothing's really regularly scheduled
and you sort of you have to find a plane
that we could get on to come home and we
did we found an aircraft that was an
outbound era medical Mission which means
they're taking away the taking back home
fallen soldiers and and Marines and
Airmen and sailors out of the war zone
and we had to get permission from the
pilots they said yes and then we waited
and waited and waited and waited and
waited and waited and waited and waited
and waited and waited and eventually we
got on the plane
all of our stuff was strapped down and
about five minutes before we were
supposed to leave the pilot came up to
us and says I need to bump you I need
more room for stretchers
and if there's ever a good reason to get
bumped off a plane this is about as good
as it gets so we got off the plane and
now the goal was to find another plane
we could get on and that's when we found
out that there were no other planes
going in the direction we needed to go
until Tuesday and it was only Saturday
and in that moment upon receiving that
news every fiber of my being sank
um I could feel the panic coming now
that I didn't have before
I became a person that I am not and I
could see it happening like one of the
PA officers won the public affairs
officer said I can get you on a flight
to you know
Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan but you don't have
the right visa and I put my finger in
his face and I said you get me on that
plane like I don't talk to people that
way you're in fear what's that you were
in fear I I was consumed by fear right
um
uh we went back to our quarters we're
all pretty exhausted and I lay on the
bed and I close my eyes there's no way
I'm sleeping and my mind is racing but I
close my eyes one of the officers said
well I'm gonna see if I can find another
flight and he left and the office the
other officer said well I'm gonna go to
the gym
and because I was in my bed with my eyes
closed you thought I was sleeping and as
he walked out the room he turned off the
lights
I'm now left by myself in this dark room
my mind is racing and I'm consumed by
fear I am now convinced I would bet
money I am a hundred percent convinced
that there's gonna be another rocket
attack it's definitely going to land
wherever I am and the way that my
parents are going to find out that I am
in Afghanistan is the someone who's
going to knock on the door and tell them
I'm convinced
I I
don't want to be there I regretted
saying yes
I'm lonely
and I'm in the purpose business so I I
get this and so I thought to myself okay
you don't have a sense of purpose that's
what you need you need purpose you need
purpose okay so I started inventing
purpose I'm like you're here to give
witness and then come back and tell
their story
and I'd feel amazing and
and then like three minutes later
I wasn't amazing
I was back into deep panic and fear and
I would do this a couple of times I I
would come up with some nonsense and I
think we do this ourselves we come up
with some rationalized nonsense that
sort of lasts a little bit
and everything was exaggerated and
compressed for me you know
um and I I couldn't come up with
anything else and so I lay in that bed
and I I gave up
I I resigned myself
to being powerless and stuck you
surrendered surrender I I just gave up I
surrendered and and in that moment of
surrender
this intense calm came over me
I'd even go so far as to say excitement
where having now surrendered and given
myself up to the situation I decided
that I wanted to serve
that I would volunteer that would give
talks if they wanted around the base for
troop morale I would sweep floors if
they wanted me to I would carry boxes I
didn't care how menial the tasks were I
wanted to be there to serve
as if it were a movie the timing was
uncanny having just come to this
realization
having just learned what true service
means that truly to live a life of
service means the choice to serve those
who serve others
not everybody to serve those who serve
others having just come to this magical
insight as if the door flung open it was
Major Throckmorton he said there's
another flight that's leaving we can get
on it we can get it there's another
flight but we have to leave now we have
to leave now they're really going to
leave without us where's Matt like he's
at the gym
so we ran to the gym
he's on the treadmill like we gotta go
we gotta go there's another flight we
gotta go just as a quick aside
I'm not a in I'm not military so I'm not
allowed to wear uniform anything like
that
and I'm wearing uh khakis and a goal
shirt
which is like contractor wear
and a pair of boots and I'm scruffy and
I'm little
so I kind of look like Special Forces
so when all the other troops see me run
into the gym go up to Once one guy and
go we gotta go we gotta go we gotta go
they're all like
what's going on
that was my little thrill
is there anyway we ran back to our
quarters we grabbed our stuff he didn't
have time to shower he threw his uniform
back on we grabbed our packs and ran out
to the the flight line
to catch our plane as soon as we got to
the flight line we could see the C-17
that we were going to board and just as
we got there a security Cordon came down
and they wouldn't let us onto the field
because somewhere else on base
there was a fallen soldier ceremony
happening and what happens is out of
respect everything on base stops
and so we sat on the curb and we waited
and why we were sitting on the curb I
told the guys what I had just gone
through in the bed
and I I wept
it brings me to tears now I wept as I
told them the story and one thing people
don't realize about the military is
crying is just fine it's just fine
there's a lot of crying and it's just
fine
they hold space
yeah and uh we finally the security
Cordon came back up and we went and
boarded our our aircraft
and what I haven't told you is the
reason that this was an unscheduled
aircraft and the reason
um it showed up as we would be carrying
the soldier for whom they just had
the ceremony
we got on the plane we're the only three
passengers on that plane
and the Army brought upon the aircraft a
single flag drape casket and laid it in
the middle of the cargo bay
and all of the Airmen stood at attention
I didn't know what to do and I put my
hand on my heart I kind of felt like an
idiot and so I just stood at attention
with them in this perfect line as the
Army laid down the casket they did a
slow eight count salute to say goodbye
to their comrade we watched them March
off the plane hug and cry as they walked
out of sight the air crew got to work
and strapped down the precious cargo and
then we left it was a nine and a half
hour flight overnight back to Ramstein
back to Germany
and as soon as we got in the air
everybody like staked out a piece of
real estate to get some sleep and I was
last because they all sort of scattered
and so I was left uh sleeping next to
the casket
um on every other flight I was on WE
joked we talked we had a blast on every
other flight on this flight barely a
word was spoken on every other flight I
hung out in the cockpit talked to the
pilots on this flight I never visited
the cockpit once
um and I will tell you it was the
greatest honor of my life having just
learned what true service means getting
to bring home someone who understands
service more than I ever will
we get to Bagram we get to Ramstein and
our final flight home is uh an an air
medical evacuation where we're bringing
wounded the wounded back to America from
Germany
um some of them ambulatory some of them
not and it's a more relaxed on this
flight but in the back of the aircraft
there's a single Gurney
it was nurses attending to a whole bunch
of troops and there's a there's like
four doctors tending to one Marine who's
what they call ccat which is an
artificial coma
uh and I sort of stayed away out of
discomfort from the back of the plane
and I sort of like at some point like I
should really go so I went back and
talked to the docs and they were telling
me his wounds his buddy had stepped on
an IED and was killed and he took the
shrapnel he had traveled in the chest he
lost an eye
um shrapnel in the skull and
um and they were telling me how uh some
of the trauma care that was being
developed in Afghanistan and Iraq was
slowly making its way to civilian
hospitals back home so even when they're
wounded they're giving back to us
and the head doc the guy in charge was a
reservist from Austin
who works in an ER and I I asked him a
question had I not gone through what I
went through I asked him a question I
would never have asked him
I said I said you're a good guy you work
in an ER you save lives for a living
are these missions different than your
job back home
and he looked at me said there is no
comparison
he said 90 to 95 of the people who come
through the ER are either drunks or
idiots
he says there's not a single drunk or
idiot here he says the honor I get on
these missions
doesn't equate to an entire career
we made it back to Ramstein back to
Andrews Air Force Base we made it back
to Andrews Air Force Base we were the
last plane to land right before a huge
storm came in
which was amazing that they let us land
and we got off Andrews and there was
this the biggest rainbow I've ever seen
in my life
over over the over the base
I'll tell you one final piece to this
the deal I made with the general was
that I would go do my thing and then he
wanted me to come back to headquarters
and Report out what I had seen and share
any insights that I may have gleaned
and so about two weeks later I went back
to headquarters and did just that and I
stood in an auditorium
smaller than this and all of the brass
was there all the generals a bunch of
Colonels like all the brass were there
and I told him what I went through in
the airdrop and some things that I was
really impressed by and the little
tweaks that I could see and I was going
over in my head do I want to tell the
story of coming home with this casket
and I sort of like was debating and I
finally decided to tell the story And
the emotions were raw I mean it had just
happened
And the emotions were raw and
I started telling the story and I
couldn't
I swelled up and I I couldn't I couldn't
get the words out
and something magical happened
and you realize the difference between
private sector and these magical human
beings
if I and it's happened if I'm on a stage
and I well up and I get stuck somebody
in private sector will say it's okay
don't worry
right as if to push you aside
when I got stuck and welled up on that
stage
two words were spoken by the four star
who was sitting at the back of the room
he said
go on
as if to say go on you're safe or go and
we're with you
and that's amazing yeah he didn't say
stop
in a time of pain in a time of fear in a
time of overwhelm he did not say stop he
said go on
and this is why I wrote that book
because you realize the power
of community the power of friendship the
power of of a strong culture that is
built on love and I don't use that term
lightly if you ask folks in the military
I've I've talked to the the hardest of
Hardcore Warriors and I say what is it
that makes you good at what you do and
they say love they say love they love
each other we call each other colleagues
and co-workers they call each other
brother and sister and that relationship
is real
and from that day on when my friends
struggle I say go on
and that's why that book exists
so powerful and that
that experience changed you
I am who I am in part because of that
I think
what people don't understand and I think
something that keeps us
from
going deeper into character and going
deeper into service
is there's this misconception that we're
supposed to be born this way
it's supposed to be natural and we're
supposed to be a good person and we're
supposed to be unselfish and we're
supposed to be honest and not yell at
people and not get frustrated
and in my experience that is not the
case
it is an unnatural way of being it is a
way of being that forces us to go into
the Shadows to look at our base
operating system and realize its flaws
and realize that there are two parts of
us there's the part that is
fearful and selfish and
self-preservationists and greedy and
then there's a higher part that we can
cultivate
and that we can train but it but it
takes practice
when you are sitting with leaders or
people that want to transform that are
brave enough to know that they need to
be better
how did they start what's the work
it's not I mean I
I wish I had something profound to tell
you I mean
you know the first step is you know
admitting you have a problem you know
yeah
um this is all sounding familiar you
know there's
there's a great irony in Being Human
which is it's really hard to be human on
question my cats don't have to work hard
to be cats no
but humans have to work really hard to
be humans be good humans for sure you
know yeah and there's that's that's
funny to me you know that it's that it's
not just natural in fact if it's just
Instinct it's not going to go well
um and uh I think to accept the fact
that human beings and human
relationships are and will always be
messy
is is part of it to know that I am messy
you are messy we are messy all of my
relationships are messy and I we are
constantly working on the skills to find
order in the chaos and make it just a
little less messy today
but it's always going to be messy
and I think the first part of what
you're talking about the question you're
asking you are better qualified to
answer than me which is it starts with
accountability and you were in my
opinion and the reason I have such love
for you is you are the patron saint of
accountability
uh
because
when you are faced with a situation
where self-preservation was an option
you chose not to take it
and your example is so extreme
just just really a quick aside for those
who don't know when Molly was busted by
the feds
um
do you know who Molly is
[Applause]
so
it's Molly
uh
when Molly was busted by the feds they
offered her a deal that she could stay
out of jail if she simply just gave up
some names
or she could not take the deal and
she'll face this criminal justice system
and I think it's fair to say that none
of these people were your friends they
were just people you did business with
they weren't like you had no emotional
loyalty to them whatsoever and I think
it's fair to say that a hundred percent
of the people in this room would have
taken the deal to stay out of jail and
you said no you said I'm not taking the
deal I choose accountability which is
why your example is important because
it's so extreme
um and what I have learned from the
people that I've talked to and which is
um meant the more senior they get the
more the better skilled they are
at the at the shield
uh the better skill they are at giving
the answer to avoid the question
the better skill they are at masking
vulnerability or even showing
vulnerability
um and if they do they're really good at
faking it too
um and so the ones that truly do the
work are the ones that even in private I
don't expect them to necessarily make
Grand pronouncements
who um display their their Humanity
and accept accountability
and want to be better for whatever
whatever reason
um and it is a pretty amazing thing when
you sit with someone powerful and they
cry
um and if there are some people in this
room who are my friends and so you'll
know this but I have a rule with all of
my friends which is there's no crying
alone
but if you are in a state where that
level of emotion if you start talking
about something that you know tears are
going to follow you immediately pick up
the phone and call me or somebody else
and there's no crying alone it's just
not allowed and
um the willingness to allow someone to
sit in mud with you
is the is what it is to be human I think
it is it is the greatest honor and I've
been I've been thinking about this a lot
lately which is you know when our
friends are struggling our instinct is
to rescue them to pull them out of the
mud to fix to fix and if you're the one
sitting in the mud when somebody
attempts to fix even if it's
well-intentioned it is the it is a
horrible feeling
just don't do that you're making it
worse
and what true friendship is is not the
desire to fix or pull the friend out of
the mud who you really want to see out
of the mud
but it's your willingness to sit in the
mud with them to get in the mud and turn
them away and say
this sucks
you know and it's not fun being in the
mud with them you don't want to get in
the mud with them
um but you choose to get in mud with
them until they're ready to say can we
get out now
but you sit there with them and that's a
friend of mine who he's one of those
folks
I hadn't talked to him in a while and I
called them up and be like what are you
up to I haven't talked in a while and he
he opened up and it was intense
and
I was like why didn't you call me
he's like I didn't want to bother you
and the end of our the way we ended the
phone call
is I said I didn't say I'm always here
I'll be here
you know I took my go on sort of
mentality and the way we ended the phone
call is like listen
um and he's you know he's he's depressed
and he's in a bad place the way we ended
the phone call is I said listen
um don't be an
and deny me the honor of being there for
you
like don't you have no right
very teary day today
I think
that it's you don't know
how healing and how cathartic it is
to get in the mud with someone
to make your life about something
greater than yourself to give of
yourself to help another person until
you walk through it
and
I have seen
after everything fell apart in my life
uh other than being a convicted I was
also
um I had I had a huge dependence on
drugs and alcohol
and
I went to I was part of a 12-step
program which was the best education of
my life
and what I would see is people walk in
to these rooms done finished life burned
to the ground hated themselves we're so
spiritually sick they would rather be
killing themselves than be present
and it wasn't putting down the drug or
the alcohol
it started to be about the work you do
with forgiveness and living a more
principled life
but when you see the lights truly go
back on when you see a human being
become healed from that almost
impossible state of being
is when they turn around and they share
it with another one when they sponsor
another person when they walk another
person through the fire that's when you
see that human being transform
AAA is magical it is
um and we know we we all sort of know
the first step is admitting up a problem
but I think people don't realize what
the 12th step is right and AAA knows
this which is if you master all 11 steps
and not the 12th you're probably going
to succumb to the disease right but if
you can Master the 12th step you're more
likely to beat it the 12th step is to
help another alcoholic that's right the
12th step is service that's right and
you learn more as the person who steps
in the mud to be with the other person
than the person being in the mud no
question and brene brown talks about
this all the time which is we don't
build trust by offering help we build
trust by asking for it
oh
huge step
and
Edge living example of of this the truth
of of what you talk about
um
can we take the sacrifice too far
simple answer is yes yes um service is
not martyrdom
and I think that and I've seen this you
see in various forms
um but you know where you start it's
it's it's sort of the the
is sort of opposite side of the spectrum
of people who need immense amount of
external validation like likes and
followers to to feel good about
themselves which is if I if I all I do
is help others a great personal
sacrifice I'm a good person and to the
point of complete self-destruction and
I've seen it in many forms
um you know there's controversial but
Mother Teresa apparently and they found
these letters after she died where she
started to question the existence of God
and wasn't a happy person and she's the
poster child for like giving your life
completely to others
um and never thinking about yourself and
um uh I've seen this with like young
young
um young leaders I I knew this young
leader she had a couple of direct
reports I think she was a first time
manager
and she would send her folks home at a
reasonable hour because she didn't she
wanted to create a good work environment
where they weren't working late and then
she would stay at work every day until
11 or 12 to finish their work
because she felt that that was being a
good leader is sacrificing herself
constantly for her people
um to the point where she's burning out
and they get lazy because they're like
bye she's gonna finish it you know
um and it has the opposite experience
and the reality is and this has been
talked about multiple times even by
folks on the on the stage uh you know on
this event at this event which is you
struggle really matters you know you
know overcoming a difficult task and
feeling proud of getting through it or
working late and being like I did that
you know
um it it's it's not only shared hardship
is actually
that produces relationship I mean if you
go through struggle with someone you do
actually you do build bonds
um
um and you know I think we've moved away
from helicopter parents and we've become
like sort of duvet parents where
everything is a soft Landing you know
um not my experience but yeah but I
think I think um we've become very
uncomfortable with discomfort
um and I think discomfort is part of the
work of Being Human and learning to be
uncomfortable not to avoid it but
learning how to how to manage it so uh
yeah there is such thing as as too much
service yes my dad calls it constructive
suffering yeah that's a good that's good
that's very good
um which means it's managed which means
it's not throw you in the deep end but
it's throwing your deep end but I'm
standing on the side just in case right
right it's managed yeah right that's
good um I want to see I want to take
some questions from the audience
can we turn the house lights up please
yeah
right back there
you you yes
just shout shout and I'll repeat it
hi
thank you
just shout okay we're gonna repeat the
question
[Music]
how's your destination
so the question is has my definition of
success and achievement changed
apparently on page 180
[Laughter]
that that book is older than 10 years
uh I I make the distinction that
achievement matters because success is
just a feeling
and so we talk about you know you don't
say are you successful do you feel
successful I mean that's really what it
is right because are you successful we
semantic but we confuse with achievement
like I have accomplished this and human
beings are tangibly driven animals
um we need milestones we need metrics
those are there's nothing wrong with
that but the important thing is is that
to what end
and so you can have achievement but not
feel successful there we all know people
who've achieved remarkable things but
aren't happy people they don't feel
successful they keep working harder and
harder hoping that that feeling will
come and yet we all know people who buy
you know Western standards haven't
achieved much but feel very successful
um and so
um I think uh you know the idea of
pursuing happiness which is sort of an
industry now it's a cottage industry you
know I think is uh I I I I I don't know
if you can I don't know if that's true
you know I think you can uh if you persu
I I there's no I don't there's no skill
set to pursue happiness
you know what do I but I think if you
pursue things like better relationships
I think if you pursue things like
empathy if you pursue things like
finding balance between social media and
my real life you know the best
definition the best description of
Instagram I just saw which is uh um
happy pictures of unhappy people
ha
wrong with any of those things the
balance is off
so I I think to to understand that
achievement towards something
is more likely to produce feelings of
success because what you're counting is
momentum rather than absolutes
and momentum is the thing and the thing
that I go to when I feel like my
reminder is the women's suffrage
movement in the United States is that
every single founder of the women's
suffrage movement in the United States
had died of natural causes before the
first woman voted
do you feel that they were successful in
their deathbeds I can guarantee you the
answers yes it's because they could see
the momentum that they were building and
though they had wished it happened in
their lifetime I guarantee they died
with confidence that it was going to
happen
and that to me is where the feeling of
success comes from that you're
contributing to the flywheel you're
contributing to the momentum and the
achievement is very focused
sure
in other words second place isn't
necessarily the first loser
yeah I mean he's quoting John Wooden the
one of the winning most coaches of all
time that success is being the best you
can be and second place is not
necessarily for his loser and I think
it's also worth adding that wooden one
of the most successful coaches in
history was not obsessed with winning
he was obsessed with Team Building
conversion I've always lived that I am
my competition
absolutely
hi
um
uh obviously you've achieved a lot
do you view yourself as successful and
if you do or if you don't what do you
what are the things that have made you
feel like you have been successful or
not
next question no no no no
okay
yeah thank you yeah
she asked she asked uh am I successful
do I feel like I'm successful uh and
something like that
um
and how do I know or don't know
uh the answer is I'm not sure
um I I the way I've always viewed my
career is like an iceberg which is when
I first had a vision of what the world
could be
I saw the iceberg beneath the ocean and
nothing was sticking above the ocean
only I could see what was beneath it was
called vision
it lived in my imagination
and people would be like
and I got a bit better at it describing
it in words that other people could
imagine what I can imagine
and that means a little bit of the
iceberg popped up because somebody else
could see it
but it's still in our imaginations
and then I could do some work that would
spread the message a little more and now
more people could see it so there's a
little more Iceberg and so people would
say it's amazing what you did it'd be
like tip of the iceberg
um and then as time progressed
um more of the iceberg
showed up and books and talks and talks
that go viral I mean I've been fortunate
to win the internet lottery a couple of
times
and
um and no matter how much iceberg is
sticking above the ocean which is how
people are judging My Success look how
successful you are because they're
looking above the ocean what I see is so
much more beneath the ocean
and so
I'm I know I'm supposed to
celebrate above the ocean
but I spend most of my time looking
beneath the ocean
and so no matter what I've done or how
the people wanted to find success and
they say things like You're so
successful my answer still is tip of the
iceberg
um and
for me again momentum matters more than
anything
and you know if if there's
if there's one thing I'm really proud of
you know rather than feeling of success
so if there's one thing I'm really proud
of
it's that the concept of why
is part of the vernacular
that I can read a newspaper
and
it'll say this company clearly didn't
know their why with no reference to me
the journalist probably had no idea
where it came from
and uh and that is now a universally
accepted concept which wasn't the case a
bunch of years ago in other words I
found language that made the idea of
purpose at work a real thing
I'm very proud of that
um
and I'm even more proud of the fact that
most people don't know where it came
from
and to me success
is the impact not the credit
and so I guess I do feel successful like
[Applause]
I think we have time for one more
go on a pie a pie
CE
and how to potentially avoid burnout
um
uh
uh this is where relationships matter
um you know I it's not a
it's not a fair question because it's
not a formula
right
um
um and what I have learned is that the
quality of our relationships will have
direct impact on the quality and ability
we have to push ourselves beyond our own
limits
so
um
you know
all you need is one person in your life
who says you got this I believe in you
and you will find courage and energy to
do things that you would not have had
before but more importantly
um that person needs to also say and if
everything goes wrong I will be there
for you and I will be there with you and
I will be in the mud with you
um and has the ability to say
something's wrong I'm worried about you
um and I think burnout happens when
you're attempting to do all of the
things you see other people do and not
realize that they have deep meaningful
relationships that you can't see and you
think falsely that you have to do it
alone
uh
and and
that's when burnout happens
because you don't as an individual have
the energy
but in community and in relationship and
in Friendship
um it's remarkable including knowing
when to just take a little break to
recharge
family
and family
family counts absolutely those
relationships I wish we had more time
I know there's so many more questions
Simon I think two of the most important
questions we can ask ourselves as human
beings
who are we going to fight for and how
are we going to do it and you have
answered this and continue to answer
this with your life
thank you so much for being a big part
of creating a better world for all of us
and this has been a profound honor
thank you
[Applause]